[Music]
good morning to you this is sky news
breakfast where it's seven o'clock in
the uk nine o'clock here in kiev as
ukraine's armed forces fight to save
their country from russian aggression
russia's offensive against ukraine
enters its second day with more
explosions here in the capital kiev
this is the scene as day breaks on the
capital this morning with the ukrainian
government saying 137 civilians and
military personnel have been killed
[Music]
sirens sound across kiev for a second
morning in a row as the threat of
russian air aids continues
a call to arms ukraine's president
orders a full military mobilization with
18 to 60 year old men banned from
leaving this country
what ukrainians should do
help the national defense join the
national armed forces anyone with
experience in the army it's really
important
penalties for the pariah president a
raft of fresh sanctions imposed from the
west but ukraine claimed they have been
left a fight alone
[Music]
anger at the invasion more than 1700
arrested on possible treason charges as
anti-war protests take place in more
than 50 russian cities
we will have the latest throughout the
morning from here in kiev as well as
moscow london brussels and the united
states
[Music]
so good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast live from kiev we've been left
alone to fight russia that's the message
from ukraine's president as his forces
continue to battle vladimir putin's
invasion as the russian offensive enters
its second day here putin's forces are
advancing from the north the east and
the south and the capital kiev is now
under direct threat there have been more
rocket attacks in kiev with many people
spending the night in underground
shelters here
in the last hour the international
criminal court said it may investigate
possible war crimes committed by russia
these are the latest developments so far
in the past couple of hours the
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
has announced that russian strikes on
his country resumed this morning at 4
a.m local time aimed at both military
and civilian targets
the president has ordered a full
military mobilization to counter the
russian invasion men aged 18 to 60 are
now banned from leaving this country
he says that so far 137 people have been
killed describing them as heroes
president zielinski also stated the
number of wounded as
316.
russian forces are believed to have
taken the chernobyl nuclear power plant
our international affairs editor
dominic waghorn has this report
a huge explosion lights up kiev
the fighting reaching the skies above
the ukrainian capital
on the ground residential buildings have
been hit
in the east of the country ukrainians
race to the shelters in the city of
mariopol under attack from russia
above ground they try and contain the
damage done by shelling to their
property and families
[Music]
i don't worry about myself i worry about
children they wake up and they cry
asking what happened mom what do i say
to him the war
he doesn't get it at all he asked what
should i do
this is thought to be hostile airport
just outside of kiev taken by russian
special forces then reportedly re-taken
by ukrainians
ukraine's president addressed his nation
last night accusing russia of wanting to
decapitate his government
my family is also in ukraine my children
are in ukraine
my family are not traitors they are
citizens of ukraine
where exactly they are i have no right
to say according to the information we
have the enemy has marked me as target
number one my family as target number
two
they want to damage ukraine politically
by destroying the head of state
ukraine's ministry of defense claims its
forces have mounted stiff resistance to
russia's attacks but russia has captured
key sites including chernobyl
sadly i have to inform you that as of
now the chernobyl zone the so-called
chernobyl exclusion zone and all the
structures of the chernobyl nuclear
power plants are under the control of
the russian armed groups
according to the management of the
chernobyl exclusion zone and the
chernobyl nuclear power plant there have
been no casualties
the information will be updated russia
claims it's defending people here in
separatist controlled eastern parts of
ukraine there has been shelling here
with casualties
in around three minutes another shell
came here right into the factory
workshop and those people were hit who
didn't have time to hide
but russia has launched far more than a
defensive operation a massive
multi-pronged invasion across ukraine's
borders raising the prospect of europe's
biggest land war since world war ii
dominic waghorn sky news moscow
and we're joined now by the defense
secretary ben wallace thank you very
much for being with us uh we were woken
this morning here by loud explosions is
it your view that the russians are
intent on taking this city and removing
president zielenski from power
it's definitely our view that the
russians intend to invite the whole of
ukraine uh the nonsense they were
spouting about the donbass and it were
you know as ever with a whole series of
dishonest claims are not the case and
that's why you've seen a number of
columns of russian army entering the
city from the south from the north from
belarus even
and indeed from the separatist region
but you know our assessment as of this
morning is that russia has not taken any
of its major objectives in fact it is
behind
its hope for timetable
they've lost over 450 personnel and
indeed as you've said on your report one
of the significant airports they were
trying to capture with their elite
spetsnaz has failed to be taken and in
fact the ukrainians have taken it back
so i think contrary to great russian
claims and indeed president putin's sort
of vision that somehow the ukrainians
would be liberated and would be flocking
to his cause
he's got that completely wrong and the
russian army has failed to deliver on
day one its main
objective even so i mean the explosions
this morning are getting closer we're
told russian forces are making their way
here albeit with some resistance
if they do
uh topple this government do you accept
that the west has failed ukraine
well what i have said all along is that
ukraine needs its support and allies the
united kingdom sweden for example canada
and a number of other countries have
stood side by side of ukraine since 2014
we had operation orbital to help set up
and train we trained over 20 000
ukrainian soldiers
we were the first country to deploy
lethal aid to help the ukrainians in
europe alongside the united states and
now we're joined by four or five other
european countries i'm pleased to say
but you know the person who has failed
to live up to all his agreements
including the agreements that he has
signed as lately as 2010 or certainly
the russian federation has been
president putin he's failed to follow
international law he failed to respond
but the west democracy with respect
no with respect i mean the west has
failed to persuade president putin that
the price of invasion
is too high
i wrote an article in july january that
president putin was beyond this type of
persuasion you know president putin
i said and got criticized at the time
there was a whiff of munich about
president putin and it wasn't about the
bit about appeasement i was referring to
i was referring that in the munich in
1938 adolf hitler all along had a plan
to invade parts of europe and all the
diplomacy was about a straw man sort of
attempt by him to buy time putin has
been set on this for many many months
and certainly over a year
and i think that's why
you know it doesn't matter how much
effort we made and we all made
unbelievable answer effort we saw
president macron go with my prime
minister regularly spoke to putin didn't
matter
as we're seeing today it's not about the
donbass it's not about a minority it is
about agreed to subsume ukraine into the
russian federation or indeed uh for
president putin to land grab in a way
right but if you saw it coming
a year ago months ago
shouldn't the west and nato have been
more uh prepared for this let me just
read you what president zielenski who is
in this city we think somewhere probably
in his bunker somewhere let me read you
what he said this morning he said we are
defending our state alone
like yesterday the world's most powerful
forces are watching from afar
as a military man how does that make you
feel
well
what it makes me feel is it is the same
thing that you know many many people in
the west felt which was what you are
seeing on your cameras today is
illogical president putin didn't need to
do this he didn't need to
occupy which he's doing right now a
sovereign country he didn't none of it
stacked up none of the reasons why he
would do it would stack up a few of us
felt that
and you know again i made a few comments
the other day about president putin you
know he's not doing something that's
logical he's doing something that is
about his ego and his legacy so you know
the west will act in accordance sorry
i'm talking about the west though mr
wallace i'm talking about the west's
response doing regardless of any nato
articles or rules is there not a moral
responsibility
on the west to protect a democratic
state from a
paranoid autocratic dictator
isn't that just basic humanity and
isn't that a moral
mission
well
it absolutely is a moral remission which
is why we have taken the step of some of
the toughest sanctions to be placed on
russia going in now he's still that's
not working
he's not working the shells are coming
in no no the missiles
hang on as you say president
okay so there are two other options mark
which is if you think president putin is
absolutely uh you know irrational tyrant
et cetera and all those things that you
have just said
which many of us do think he is in a
position that is beyond logic beyond
respect of other sovereign countries
there are a number of ways to stop him
or make it cost him one is sanctions one
is to help the ukrainians defend
themselves which is lethal aid which we
did alongside the united states quite
early on and training
we announced over a year ago that we
would be selling uh ships to ukraine uh
with missiles that would allow them to
defend their ports you know we have done
a lot the third option which is the
option that i've been quite open about
just to interrupt on that one just to
interrupt how are you going to get any
more military aid into this country if
it is controlled by the russians they
will control the airspace they will
control the borders and they will
control the sea borders how do you get
any more military help to help this it's
not going to happen is it
well
i'm not going to tell you with all due
respect how we're going to do these
things because that would put a lie risk
the lives of the people that we are
supporting and indeed uh you know other
people so so look what i would say is so
the military could come in so so we
could have the military coming in no i
didn't say military i said how he could
support i didn't say the military stop
jumping to lots of things i said
it is perfectly possible on a country
that is the size of germany and france
put together with 44 million people
russia does not control the whole of
ukraine at all russia as i said this
morning has failed in its day one
objectives russia with its spec snaps
its so-called elite hasn't even been
able to take an airport that it took
yesterday russia has lost significant
amounts of armor and people the
ukrainians are fighting and they are
fighting brave it is perfectly possible
for countries around europe and the
world in fact as you i do agree with you
it is their moral duty to help the
ukraine it is perfectly possible to
continue to support ukraine as we speak
as you are standing in kiev to make sure
that we give them all the aid whether it
is non-lethal aid or where possible it
is defensive lethal aid to help them
defend themselves that is possible
ukraine has a lot of fight in it you've
seen that over the night
president putin is not getting it the
way he wishes it to do and he's
currently got forces that far outnumber
ukraine but it is possible but i'm
afraid i'm not going to go on national
television and describe how we will help
ukraine because to do that you know in a
war footing scenario is to put people at
risk
right right okay
this is an unprovoked and completely
unjustifiable attack on a democratic
nation does that in your view amount to
a war crime well it certainly amounts to
a breach of international law in
anyone's definition and what happens on
the ground is the responsibility of the
russian federation we summoned the
defense attache to the ministry of
defense yesterday i made sure he was
reminded of his obligations under the
geneva convention
the track record of russians in places
like chechnya is not good but
nevertheless those commanders whether
they are senior or junior will be held
responsible and in this day and age the
good news is we know who they are we can
find out who they are should they commit
war crimes and we will pursue them no
matter what happens in ukraine the west
will pursue them the united kingdom will
pursue them and president putin who has
done this he has to fail whether he
fails militarily or whether he fails
for the rest of his reign so to speak in
ukraine he has to fail he has to fail
because he is fighting our values and he
is fighting all the human rights that we
stand for and i don't know whether he'll
fail in ukraine we will do everything we
can to make sure he does but if he
doesn't he needs to fail after that
if if if you are going to track these
people down and you're going to hold
them to account does that mean
we will see president putin in a war
crimes court is that what you would like
to see and do you think that will ever
happen
if president putin commits a war crime
then just as i do if i were to commit a
war crime i should expect to be held to
account but you know what we're saying
at the moment isn't this already a war
crime
well i i i'm not i'm afraid the the
international lawyer i couldn't tell you
the difference between breaking
international law in so far as directing
your forces to invade another country
versus a war crime eg things like
genocide and indeed
you know torture and
etc so i i wouldn't want to speculate
the difference is what i would say is
he's clearly broken international law
he's occupying or trying to occupy a
sovereign country who made one mistake
in his eyes his mistak their mistake in
his eyes was not to choose the kremlin
as a way for their future and that's all
they have done
and as we see on our telly president
putin's response to that is ultimate
force destruction lots of civilian areas
bombed and we must all never never
forget
that okay and just finally are you more
convinced now than ever that putin has
gone full tonto as you put it that he's
irrational lost his mind
i certainly think what he is doing is
deeply irrational i certainly think he
is
gone full tonto if that's what you know
what i said the other day and talking to
some soldiers you know no one else in
their right mind would do what we are
seeing on our telescreens today uh you
know no one else would impose their will
on another sovereign country
with all sorts of concocted conspiracies
and very bizarre readings of history uh
unless somehow they were acting deeply
irrationally
but that doesn't that's no comfort to
people of kiev i spoke to my defense
counterpart only a few minutes ago
and we spoke to them last night myself
in the foreign secretary our prime
minister is going to speak to president
zielenski and we will keep on going
supporting the people of ukraine
ben wallace good of you to talk to us
thank you very much
right let's see how russia is attacking
ukraine from the north and the east and
from the south the offensive began in
the donbass region to the east but
there's now been
over 200 attacks according to the
ukrainian national police service let's
look at the capital kiev where i am
where the mayor vladimir klitschko
says three people have been injured with
one in critical condition after a rocket
attack on a residential building
there's also a battle going on for the
hostamel air base
while british intelligence claims it's
highly likely russia has captured the
chernobyl nuclear plant to the north of
kiev
what about kharkiv near the russian
border uh where uh russian attacks have
focused on the ukrainian military
including an air base in uh nearby
chihuahua
the mayor of rivny in ukraine's north
west says the city's airport faced
missile strikes this morning but no one
was injured and no serious damage
recorded there shelling has been
reported in levov and that's in the west
and close to the polish border and it
may soon find itself hosting refugees
from other parts of this country
at least 18 people have been killed in a
missile attack in odessa in the south
west it's a significant port complex
important for russian forces to control
ukrainian authorities said parts of the
kherson region along the crimean coast
are no longer under their control
let's get
the latest from around ukraine now skies
john sparks is in ukraine's second
biggest city of kharkiv
near the border with russia and john
just give me an idea
uh day two of this uh operation has
dawned what are you seeing and what are
you hearing
uh good morning mark yes we we believe
that the russian military is moving as
in kiev they are moving here in hakib to
surround
the city despite obstacles they will be
facing from the weather this morning
we've still
heard artillery fire just five minutes
ago the
thud of incoming
shells so we all know they're here and
we all know that they're close uh close
by
the ukrainian military is clearly
seeding ground there is a city about a
one and a half hour drive northwest of
here called sumi we understand that the
russian military has now occupied that
city and are erecting roadblocks on the
highways leading to kiev although
the ukrainian president says that his
forces are managing to stop the russian
military in most directions but i think
that kiev is is a main probably the main
objective here intense fighting as you
know overnight missile strikes loud
explosions the air raid siren was
sounding and a russian
aircraft i'm not sure if it was manned
or unmanned it was brought down by
ukrainian forces overnight and the
debris crashed into a residential
building and you know we're talking
about
you know
european capital city here of nearly
three million people i mean
absolutely terrifying for
the residents there we also heard
overnight from the ukrainian president
zielenski he released a short
video message i mean this guy was acting
in a comedy series until a few years ago
now he is under the most extraordinary
pressure he was unshaven
he was in a in a t-shirt he warned the
ukrainian public of saboteurs entering
kiev he told them that he was the number
one target for the russians the number
two target being members of his family
and i think his i think he is right
vladimir putin clearly wants to get rid
of him and establish political control
over
ukraine
and he said 137 people ukrainian
citizens either civilians or in the
military have been killed they are
killing people and turning peaceful
cities into military targets he said
john sparks in kharkiv just 25 or so
miles from the russian border thank you
very much indeed let's go to our
international affairs editor dominic
waghorn who joins me now
from moscow and dominic i don't know
whether you heard the defense secretary
ben wallace just now but he
suggested that they would be tracking
down and holding to account those
responsible for war crimes here in
ukraine during this operation
also suggesting that putin himself could
be in the frame
yeah and the west is trying to find a
strategy that replaces its strategy of
deterrence which has
failed deterrence and sanctions and
military supply so far has done nothing
to avert this extraordinary attack by
russia's president on um a neighbor an
unprovoked attack an attack that
undermines the entire security order
that has kept us safe since the second
world war and it shouldn't really come
as any surprise if you look at putin's
rhetoric what he's been writing about
recently what he said on on monday um he
clearly sees ukraine as illegitimate an
artificial state
and therefore although it's an
independent sovereign state he believes
um it has no right to exist effectively
and the ukrainians and russians are one
people and therefore he has a right to
send in his troops and his forces
effectively to reabsorb it into russia
if that is his intention and that is a
direct challenge a rejection of the
principles that have uh kept us safe
since the second world war ukraine's not
a nato member but what putin is doing is
trampling uh principles that nato stands
for principles of independence
sovereignty self-determination freedom
and democracy and so far what nato has
done and what the west has done and
threatened to do is not deterring
vladimir putin from going any further i
think the worry for the west obviously
you know quite apart from what it means
for security and the cons on the
continent is that if you look at his
rhetoric what he's been saying it
implies that the same kind of principles
the idea that the that ukraine's uh loss
from the soviet empire was a grievance
applies also to the baltic states and
other former soviet states so if he's
able to get away with what he's getting
away with so far in ukraine um it is a
threat to those states as well so the
west is effectively uh wrestling with
what to do next uh this threat of war
crimes being brought against putin and
commanders the threat of more military
supplies being sent into ukraine to
support the ukrainian resistance against
this operation all that designed to try
and avert what has happened but it may
take more than that for the west to
reverse what vladimir putin is doing in
terms of the way the russians are seeing
this mark it depends really on who you
are and where you're getting your media
your information from if you're more
educated
and have access to the internet and are
savvy in terms of
accessing information um you are seeing
a fuller picture of this multi-pronged
multi-front invasion that's going on
in ukraine and that is leading to
protests hundreds if not thousands of
people coming out of the onto the
streets more than 50 cities saw protests
last night and 1700 people were arrested
so that's testament i think to the
strength of feeling amongst russians but
also to the determination by the russian
government to trample any unrest it does
not want to have civil unrest
undermining its position while it's
waging a military operation in ukraine
if you are less educated poorer and you
rely on state media for your information
you're getting a very different picture
you're being told that this is still a
very limited special military operation
the ministry of defense here in russia
has said that this is purely it's only
talking about a defensive operation
protecting the renegade republics in the
east and also saying there's a limited
operation from crimea trying to unblock
the crimean canal so a surreal um
false version of events being put out by
russia's defence ministry ministry while
its military are conducting this
extraordinary unprovoked attack on
ukraine
yeah and just briefly uh dominic um
there are suggestions today that things
are not going entirely russia's way in
this operation and that uh they're not
meeting their objectives according to
ben wallace their day one objective
certainly and that the ukrainians are
putting up quite a fight
yeah and uh ben wallace saying that 450
russians have been killed and it doesn't
seem as though that they've taken any
air bases i think there was the reports
that the spec snaps russian special
forces had taken hostimal airport just
outside of where you are in kiev but it
seems the ukrainians at least claiming
that they've retaken that air base
and i think if the russians had aimed to
encircle kiev by now they've failed to
do so but as i say none of that is being
acknowledged on russian state media in
terms of what the russians are being
told at the moment this is simply about
defending those renegade republics in
the east
and launching some kind of limited
operation from crimea we're going to
hear from maria zakharova the foreign
ministry spokesperson later in what
could be a lengthy press conference so
we'll have to see whether she addresses
any of that in her press conference but
obviously everything the russian media
says and the russian government says
should be treated with a lot of
skepticism given their track record of
lying and deceiving in the past over the
conflicts in syria chechnya are downing
of the civilian airline mh17 and so on
yeah that is probably true dominic thank
you very much indeed
well joe biden has confirmed that the
leaders of 30 nato nations will meet on
friday as they come under increasing
pressure to go even further
than sanctions on russia already
announced let's speak to greg milam who
is in
the united states for us and greg i mean
i wonder what the americans will think
as
russian forces close in on this capital
city and the plan seems to be to topple
the government of a democratic state
yeah i think that there is a there is a
sense of of frustration powerlessness i
think they they know the world is
watching the violence that's unfolding
in in ukraine and yet they can't offer
that any sense of the retribution if you
like of fighting back militarily that's
that's clear so we're left with
sanctions which can feel like a slow
burn diplomatic
response which isn't enough for a lot of
people but that they're left uh now
trying to persuade uh all of us that
that is that is the right response joe
biden saying that these these sanctions
they've put in place will be devastating
they will turn russia into a second rate
power in the short term and in the long
term as well
uh freezing assets travel bans financial
hits
and in particular this export ban on
things like semiconductors
which they think will hit the russian
military and the aviation sector the
aerospace sector
uh so they say those are significant
they're not taking that decision that
ukraine certainly wants them to take
which is to ban russia from the swift
bank messaging system
which would be a big hit but joe biden
clearly saying that europe doesn't want
that to happen at the moment but still
on the table the idea that putin himself
could be sanctioned the issue there is
finding out exactly what vladimir putin
has by way of assets and where they are
they've been elusive over the years
it is rare also to sanction a head of
state so they say they're going for
those close to him to increase the
pressure on him
that by way of sanctions and and
militarily they have the options we keep
hearing about you mention that nato
heads of government and summit uh
tomorrow morning washington time
that they believe bolstering nato can be
significant but clearly not enough for a
lot of people when when they see and
what the intelligence services here in
the u.s sees is going on on the ground
okay greg thank you very much indeed
this is sky news breakfast from the
ukrainian capital kiev on day two
of this russian assault on ukraine here
are some of the latest developments this
morning
in the past couple of hours the
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
has announced that russian strikes on
his country resumed this morning at 4 am
local time aimed at both military and he
says civilian targets the president has
ordered a full military mobilization to
counter the russian invasion
men aged 18 to 60 have been banned from
leaving this country
he says that so far 137 people have been
killed describing them as heroes
president zielenski also stated the
number of wounded as
316.
and in the last few minutes the uk
defense secretary ben wallace told me
that the russians have lost more than
450
personnel
it's definitely our view that the
russians intend to invite the whole of
ukraine
the nonsense they were spouting about
the donbass and it were
you know as ever with a whole series of
dishonest claims are not the case and
that's why you've seen a number of
columns of russian army entering the
city from the south from the north from
belarus even and indeed from the
separatist region but you know our
assessment as of this morning is that
russia has not taken any of its major
objectives in fact it is behind
its hoped-for timetable
they've lost over 450 personnel
let's speak to joe pike who's in downing
street this morning for us and joe what
did you make of what ben wallace had to
say some quite interesting stuff about
war crimes and also
this idea of still getting military
um
you know resources into ukraine
yes mark we know that the uk government
because boris johnson has said so want
to provide
more military support to
ukrainians and especially in the army
that word we're told be about body armor
night vision goggles especially for the
reservists called up
as well as shoulder mounted anti-tank
missile systems quite small weapons
which can be used in urban areas such as
cities perhaps the capital and also can
be used inside clearly mr wallace
wanting to make it clear that he does
still intend to get those weapons into
ukraine even though of course he
wouldn't explain quite how that's
possible with russia
advancing so significantly on war crimes
what boris johnson said in the comments
yesterday to mps was that anyone who
sends a russian into a battle to kill
innocent ukrainians could be brought to
court the implication that uh vladimir
putin could be guilty of all crimes mr
wallace not wanting to be too specific
about
what potential crime could have been
committed and i suppose it may take
weeks for more uh detail to be given
another interesting fact we should be
aware of in particular when mr wallace
talks about the number of russian
casualties is that
the uk government i'm sure the ukrainian
government will want uh to be positive
about the efforts of the ukrainian army
even though western officials behind the
scenes are pretty honest about how the
two powers are not matched and in
particular how a russian army
are pretty battle hardened from wars in
syria from conflicts in ukraine in 2014
and that has meant that they are
clearly far more prepared than their
ukrainian counterparts mark
yeah and just finally i mean confirming
what he said the other day when he was
talking to the
the military um officers that he that he
does think that uh president putin has
gone full tonto as he said and that he
is acting irrationally with this
yeah delusionally he he he was trying to
i suppose try and work out as everyone
is what is going on inside vladimir
putin's ahead criminology of course and
i don't think he thinks mark that what
vladimir putin is doing is logical
and therefore i think it's important for
the uk government to uh highlight that
problem dan and putin is unpredictable
yes they succeeded with intelligence
officials in predicting what vladimir
putin was going to do but that doesn't
necessarily mean they think what he is
doing
makes any sense and it won't be very
easy of course for the russian president
to maintain forces maintain control of
ukraine if he does if he does seize
control in the coming weeks in the
medium and long term
okay joe thank you very much
well european leaders met until the
early hours agreeing a second package of
sanctions on moscow among the targets
are russia's banking and energy sectors
and they come on top of a wide range of
measures announced by the united states
europe correspondent adam parsons has
this report
there was anxiety and shock among
europe's leaders as they gathered in
brussels and from those whose countries
lie near russia a sense that the eu
needed to show its teeth
this is not only the war against
ukraine
this is a war against
europe
against democracy
against the international rules based
order
and i think we cannot take the luxury to
be discussion club
and they did decide on action on what
they described as a massive package of
sanctions
it will have maximum impact on the
russian economy and the political elite
and it is built of five pillars the
first at the financial sector
second the energy sector the third is
the transport sector
fourth are export controls and the ban
of export financing and finally
visa policy
but russia was not removed from this
swift banking system
that remains an option for the future
so caustic condemnation from the
european union along with new sanctions
and the prospect of more sanctions still
to come there is a sense of furious
betrayal among many of these member
states and the ripples of that anger
spread far beyond the orbit of european
politicians
leaders from nato will discuss the
situation in a virtual meeting ukraine
is not a nato member but plenty of its
neighbors are
and of course nato's most powerful
country watches from across the atlantic
nervous or repercussions
putin is the aggressor
putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences
the looming problem is that western
diplomacy backed by ever more severe
sanctions
has now come up against russia's use of
military might
and that is a very dangerous cocktail
adam parsons sky news brussels
well skies laura bundock is in brussels
for us and laura i suppose the question
is what more can
europe do now what more can the eu do
yeah that's right i mean we saw this
sort of extended version of the
sanctions package it already said
at the beginning of the week there was a
prepared package in place and that would
contain different components this is
obviously stage two and it does go
considerably further so when it comes to
the financial markets big restrictions
on russia being able to access capital
markets uh which means it'll restrict
basically russia's ability to uh to
borrow money it'll also put a block on
russians making big deposits in eu banks
in terms of the transport sector there's
going to be a ban on the sale of
aircraft and components parts and
equipment for aircraft three-quarters of
russia's commercial fleet comes from
either europe the u.s or canada so that
will that will hit hard too and limiting
russia's access to these critical bits
of um technology things like
semiconductors which are present in all
electronic devices no move on swift yet
though that international banking system
that allows cross-border transactions to
take place there is a lot of
disagreement behind the scenes unity but
of course there are countries within the
eu who have much closer trading links
with russia who rely more heavily on
russian energy and then disagreements
too among those countries who border
russia as well if broader rather ukraine
and russia and what it might all mean
for them too we've got this meeting of
nato leaders taking place virtually we
will hear from them before and after
that meeting taking place at two o'clock
to discuss further the defensive
response there and also going alongside
the package of sanctions is this idea of
humanitarian aid now being needless
you've got the likes of poland moldova
hungary already saying they're expecting
and are witnessing an influx of refugees
coming in from ukraine now
okay laura thank you very much indeed
well the uh well i should just tell you
first of all we're hearing
uh increasing
explosions uh still some distance away
but also gunfire now
and this is over to the
northeast
so these will be russian forces coming
in from
uh
northeast ukraine or even belarus
which there's a straight road down from
belarus to the capital but uh
there's quite a lot of fighting going on
it's as i say muffled and it's distant
at the moment but uh
it does sound as though the ukrainians
are putting up quite a lot of resistance
but the capital itself
as you can see there pretty quiet some
cars on the streets but uh pretty calm
although there is a fear here now or a
reality here now that
the russians are closing in
well the west has come swiftly together
to impose economic sanctions on russia
but some are critical of germany's
reaction to the crisis so far despite
halting the approval of key russian gas
pipeline nordstrom 2 many say german
action has not gone far enough
joining us now is thomas matisek a
former german ambassador to the uk and a
senior advisor at the london consulting
firm flint thank you very much indeed
for being with us and it does seem as i
was just saying that
the russians are closing in here and the
intent is to remove a democratic
government
yes well thank you uh good morning thank
you for having me
what i can say is
that after the shock of yesterday
the germans have woken up this morning
with a terrible moral hangover
the whole of german australia our
eastern policy for the last thirty years
is antatus
the motto
vandal de chandle changed by trade which
was at the basis of it if you create
economic interdependencies it will
finally lead to stabilization it leads
to the spread of the same values liberal
democracy etc
did not come through
so what does germany have to do now
i think the first thing is
to make us less dependent on russia
especially in the energy sector
and that means diversify our energy
supplies
secondly
we have to bring up our armed forces up
to speeds to modernize they are at the
moment in a terrible state not able to
present the real the deterrence which we
need we are very far away from spending
the two percent of defense
of our gdp on defense which we committed
to in the nato framework and finally and
this is my my personal opinion
um what putin did
he destroyed the nato russia act
so we are not any longer restrained from
presenting permanent troops and even
nuclear weapons in the eastern parts of
nato and i think this is something very
very important to keep in mind in the
future
and this last thing i would like to
mention this new german government is
committed to make our restrictive arms
export policy even more restrictive
so far
we have not sent any weapons to ukraine
for this and other reasons and i think
this also will be rethought so bottom
line is the germans are still under
shock they see that that eastern policy
for the last 30 years was absolutely
wrong it was a sign of political naivete
by the way shared by people like me as
well
yeah well it's interesting how this is
changing uh germany's view of their
security
uh requirements um what do you think of
what you know where nato is in all this
because
they're being forced for good reasons no
doubt being forced to stand on the
sidelines and watch this you know
democratic state be overrun
well directly of course nato cannot
intervene because ukraine is not the
name of nato member in hindsight it
would have been good in 2008 if they had
become a nato member but that's not the
case no what we have to do now is to
reinforce
the eastern nato states because there
are no buffers anymore belarus is not a
buffer anymore ukraine in the future
will not a buffer so you we will have a
situation which we had at the height of
the cold war where germany was a front
line and we see a new iron curtain which
has come down now between poland and
ukraine and this is highly dangerous
especially as is a number
of
arms control
and
disarmament treaties do not exist
anymore
putin has established tactical and
medium-range
missiles and nuclear weapons in much
greater quantities than even at the time
when helmut schmidt uh
proposed the dual decision on nato for
the inf arms control treaty
okay
thomas and madisek thank you very much
for being with us thank you for having
me well thousands of uh residents in the
uh not at all thousands of residents in
the ukrainian city of kharkiv have spent
the night in underground train stations
and makeshift bomb shelters fearing
further uh missile attacks and air
attacks by russia yevgen gorash a
ukrainian national living in glasgow
whose parents and friends are currently
in kharkiv and he is with us and we're
joined on the phone by evgen's friend
alexi who is speaking to us
from
kharkiv itself and alexa if i can just
start with you i mean
where are you and are you safe
uh hello uh hello everyone uh right now
both me and my family are safe
but yesterday was a very tense day is
for about three hours we
had
we had to hide in the shelter
uh the shelter was actually the basement
of a multi-storate house
and the situation was quite difficult
fortunately we still have uh electricity
and internet connection but it's very
poor the speed is very low
and uh
yesterday this morning started with
missiles attacks and perhaps artillery
shelling at about five o'clock in the
morning
so we spent the entire day monitoring
the news
and also our underground stations there
uh all of all of them were used as
shelters shelters for people
it must have been absolutely terrifying
for you and your
family
uh actually actually it was because
for the first time in our lives we had
artillery shelling and we heard
uh tank shots that we fired like four to
five kilometers away
but all of us are safe now and
fortunately the situation is more or
less controlled
okay well i'm very pleased to hear that
and yet again
what do you make of what is happening
right now to your country
good morning everyone hi lexi i'm happy
to hear from you as always
um yeah i just had phone conversations
with my parents in kharkiv and i i just
confirmed with them as as previous
morning that they are safe in life
they confirmed that
there are just a few people on the
streets and
they're just trying to get basic food
from shops
and
we don't know really what to expect from
this day
uh from my parents i've heard that
uh har cave resists and uh yeah as alex
he mentioned
the situation is under control
but nobody knows when
russian tanks decide to go ahead again
and cross the
the city borders
yeah so i'm very much worried and
we i was
very all the all the time on talks with
with my parents um just yesterday
and i spent the whole day on
george square with my ukrainian friends
on your square in glasgow santa and we
received massive support from local
people from
from journalists
massive attention from journalists and
mps and that's going to be our day
today as well
we will be on george square the whole
day
okay and alexei if you're still with us
um
today is another day and it looks as if
certainly here in kiev
the russian forces are getting closer do
you fear what lies ahead in the next
hours and days
uh well it is difficult uh difficult to
predict exactly what what will happen in
the next few days
but i i would say that this day and the
following night will be decisive because
uh yeah uh kharkiv still resists
uh and we receive news that now the main
target of the russian forces is kiev so
basically what they want to do is to
behead the country by taking
our president and our government
prisoners or maybe executing them
uh and as you have hand mentioned
uh
we had we had to we have to look for
some food supplies food is still
available and fresh water is still
available
and we hope that this situation will
last but as mentioned
ukraine resists ukraine resists and this
this day and the following night will
show
will show what will be their outcome
just finally alexei would you live would
you stay in ukraine if it was
a government not elected by the people
uh you see uh if you take the example of
the uh entire uh of the former soviet
union countries
if you speak about belo russia or
kazakhstan or russia they don't have any
presidential elections anymore
and they don't have any freedom of
speech
because i cannot blame all all of
russian people uh about this invasion
the main
the main people who are
let's say
who can be
the decision makers are putin and his uh
close uh connections people who are
close to him ukraine is like you know
the last
island small island of democracy and
freedom
and if if all uh if all then putin's
dream of creating or let's say
recreating the soviet union in its
second version will be very close to
completion so what i would like to ask
okay
to support us and to impose
as severe sanctions as possible i mean
real sanctions not just words but some
real sanctions that would really hurt
putin and his clothes associated
okay alexei uh you try and stay safe as
best you can and uh yevgen also thank
you both very much indeed
well the champions league final in may
was due to be held in the gazprom arena
in saint petersburg but it will be moved
now following russia's invasion of this
country jackie bell trau
is uh joining me now and i mean in the
circumstances no great surprise
no great surprise there is an emergency
meeting this morning of the uefa
executive committee and they will
confirm what you have just said that
they will strip saint petersburg of the
champions league final there's 27
members of that committee will be in on
this meeting one of them is a russian
alexander dukoff he is also the chief
executive of gazprom they are a huge
sponsor
of uefa not to mention this arena they
pump in 33 million pounds per season
for now under a lot of pressure to sever
ties with gazprom uh yesterday the
german club at schalke uh took gazprom
off the front of their shirts that's
their club sponsor uh no longer uh
there's big questions over heiroflot who
is a sponsor of manchester united
will they sever ties with them now
we don't know which city is going to be
given the champions league final that is
still under discussion but it will be
confirmed at nine o'clock
big questions as well for fifa today
because russia are still in the playoffs
for the world cup uh they're in a group
with three other teams poland the czech
republic and sweden and those three
teams have written a letter to fifa
yesterday and said we will not play
those playoff matches in russia you must
change the venue at the minute they
haven't responded but they are under
pressure to respond and of course
questions um over scotland's playoff
match they will be playing ukraine
at hamden park
obviously ukrainian football has been
suspended so that now in doubt
jackie thank you very much still to come
on sky news breakfast we'll have all the
latest live from kiev as ukrainian
forces uh battle against the russian
invasion of their country we
uh here in central kiev are hearing
explosions getting closer to this city
we're also hearing gunfire
but we're told the ukrainian forces are
putting up resistance and
their soldiers were told according to
the military here are putting up a real
fight
[Music]
[Music]
you